[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue c'est une joie de vous retrouver
autour de deux invités qui sont
aujourd'hui mathieu sous pierre bonsoir
qui soit par vous êtes consultant expert
associé à la fondation jean jaurès et
vous avez travaillé au cabinet de mme
hamel comrie la ministre socialiste du
travail c'est bien d'avoir avant 2017
dans le monde d'avant et nous
accueillons aussi jérôme sainte-marie
bonsoir jérôme ozer sondeurs comme nul
n'ignore politologue fondateur de votre
propre institut pôle inbox
vous êtes aussi essayiste et votre
dernier livre bloc contre bloc la
dynamique du maquereau nisme a été
publié aux éditions du cerf
on va parler des vaccins soit facile de
vacciner la planète entière
il semble que ce soit encore moins
facile en europe et pas seulement parce
que l'un des vaccins en l'occurrence
astrazeneca a été suspendue plus
activement la campagne de vaccination a
été suspendu avec ce produit le temps
qu'on vérifie qu'il n'y ait pas d'effets
secondaires trop grave mais le plus
inquiétant c'est peut-être ça regardez
ce graphique ce sont des chiffres qui
datent d'hier et qui compare le niveau
de vaccination rapporté à la population
bien sûr c'est un pourcentage entre
l'union européenne d'un côté et les bons
élèves que sont le royaume uni et les
etats unis alors on commence par les
plus mauvais basse et 12 7 9%
la france et puis l'italie l'allemagne
l'espagne sont autour de 8% donc
honnêtement c'est l'épaisseur du trait
et c'est normal puisque nous nous
fournissons ensemble en vaccins sauf que
quand on se compare avec les américains
et encore plus avec les britanniques on
se dit que on n'est peut-être pas très
bon on ne parle que de retard de vaccins
qui sont pas livrés de commandes qui ne
sont pas honorées peut-être que ça sent
le fiasco tout ça mais c'est pas l'avis
du président de la république lui
continue à soutenir cet engagement
européen pour les vaccins regardez
c'était ce matin dans la cour de
l'elysée le président avait sorti les
rames et ce cadre européen
je veux ici redire que nous le défendons
il permet
l'équité la solidarité la fiabilité pour
nos concitoyens il permet aussi de
monter en puissance sur la production de
vaccins et l'europe sera ici à quelques
mois l'un des endroits du monde où l'on
produit le plus de vaccins et donc ce
sont en effet des semaines les plus
difficiles que nous sommes en train de
traverser nous le savons mais il ya
clairement des perspectives devant nous
et c'est par l'europe que nous serons
plus forts sur ce sujet aussi voilà
demain il fera beau et avant de lancer
le débat je propose d'écouter un autre
point de vue il est un peu différent il
est un peu plus critique c'est celui du
premier ministre jean castex était hier
l'invité de nos confrères de bfm tv et
lui
constatant ces retards de livraison de
vaccins trouvent que l'europe ferait
bien de taper du poing sur la table il
ya des communs face à une industrie qui
est complètement surchargé et donc qui
vivre fur et à mesure vous avez raison
dans certains cas deux surcroît les
délais de livraison ne sont pas
respectées c'est profondément anormal et
il faut que l'europe montre les crocs et
qu on dise à ses laboratoires
vous devez respecter les engagements
contractuels que vous avez montré les
crocs qui veut dire y compris en justice
ceux qui ont alors je vais aller en
justice
au bout du bout peut-être en fait le but
c'est surtout d'obtenir les vaccins et
le respect des engagements
mathieu soupière le docteur laurent
alexandre qui c'est vrai a souvent la
dent dure mais qui est invitée
régulièrement ce plateau d'isère votre
place à quelques jours c'est un waterloo
européen cette campagne de vaccination
alors il ne se distingue pas ici par son
sens de la nuance
il est profond un peu un peu tôt pour le
décréter puisqu'on n'est pas du tout à
la fin de la guerre
si on reprend la métaphore guerrière du
président macron il fait peu de doute au
vu des chiffres que vous avez partagé à
l'instant il fait peu de doute qu'à ce
stade l'europe est en retard est en
retard par rapport notamment aux états
unis ou à l'angleterre la question
encore une fois est de savoir si à la
fin du match aller en retard par rapport
à l'objectif qu'elle s'est fixée et ça
honnêtement je ne suis pas en capacité
de le dire je n'observe que l'europe
encore une fois on accable de tous les
maux premièrement est le continent qui a
été le plus frappés par le virus
rappelons le quand même fois que le
virus a quitté l'asie c'est quand même
l'europe qui a pris en premier et de la
façon la plus frontale le virus et c'est
néanmoins en europe si on se compare par
exemple avec les états unis où avec
l'angleterre que en dépit de cette
attaque frontale du virus est la plus
violente du virus à ce stade on compte
un nombre de morts qui est maîtrisé et
ce nombre de morts a été maîtrisé
néanmoins parce qu'il ya une
coordination entre les états européens
notamment
vous croyez vraiment que c'est écrit
c'est grâce à ça parce que quand on a
par exemple décidé de confiner emmanuel
macron n'a pas demandé son avis à madame
von der leyen et il a eu raison
d'ailleurs
ce sont des décisions nationales non
alors quand on a décidé de reconduire
confiné où quand on a décidé de confiner
ou même encore il ya 48 heures quand on
a décidé de suspendre effectivement
l'utilisation l'utilisation pardon du du
vaccin astrazeneca
c'est vrai il n'empêche que il n'empêche
que on a bien vu que à chaque fois les
états européens avaient finalement
apprendre à peu près les mêmes mesures à
peu près en même temps ce qu'il y bien
qu'il y a un impératif une nécessité à
ce que les états européens et des
politiques qu'ils soient à minima
coordonnées et encore une fois on fait
le procès de l'europe en juste en
oubliant peut-être à chaque fois qu'il
s'agit d'une communauté d'états nations
d'états indépendants
donc il est probablement enfin il est
tout à fait absurde de comparer en
réalité le fonctionnement de l'europe et
exemple le fonctionnement des états unis
d'amérique où le fonctionnement d'un
pays tout seul comme israël ou comme
l'angleterre
rappelons encore une fois que la santé
n'était pas une compétence communautaire
et qu'il a fallu improviser face à une
pandémie
une coordination encore une fois de
politique sanitaire qui relève d'état
régalien et j'ajoute même une complexité
ans l'idée qu'on a en europe un certain
nombre de pays qui sont dans une
organisation décentralisée où la santé
et régionalisée et où donc on avait en
réalité trois niveaux de pouvoir entre
une europe qui essayait de coordonner
des états qui essayait de cadrer et des
régions qui jouaient leur propre jeu sur
le terrain parfois dans une
confrontation politique avec leur
gouverne avec leurs gouvernements
nationaux
tout ça crée nécessairement en fait des
difficultés je ne crois pas pour autant
que ça permette d'instruire de façon
profonde le procès de l'europe jérôme
sainte-marie va vous répondre je donne
mon avis en passant sur ce point très
intéressant de la santé qui n'est pas
dans les priorités européennes
effectivement et et j'ajouterais
heureusement selzach il me semble mais
c'est un point de vue que je partage
avec vous que la santé fait partie de
dés des éléments de souveraineté et que
donc il est normal que emmanuel macron
des quand tu décides de confiner ou de
mettre le couvre feu encore une fois ne
demande pas à ses voisins européens
comme il est normal que l'allemagne
quand elle veut fermer la frontière avec
la moselle en considérant qu' il ya trop
de cas de notre côté le fait sans nous
demander notre avis et je remarque que
la dernière pandémie c'était celle de
h1n1
ce sont les états nations qui ont acheté
des vaccins en l'occurrence on en avait
acheté trop nous mais au moins quand
c'était les états qui les commandait ça
allait peut-être plus vite mais ce n'est
qu'un point de vue et j'attends le vôtre
avec beaucoup d'intérêt jérôme
sainte-marie où ils ont bon je crois que
il en est de l'europe comme autrefois du
communisme qu'il y avait un régime
communiste un peu partout à chaque fois
que ça marchait mal et même que c'était
parfois tragiques et bien les
sympathisants communistes trouvez que
c'est parce qu'il est passé de
communisme alors l'europe c'est pareil
quand ça marche mal c'est qu'il ya pas
assez d'europe
bon certains arrivent à des conclusions
un peu différente
et peut-être que l' il ya quelque chose
de peut être viciée à l'intérieur je
crois qu'effectivement cette crise du
coc vide est un formidable révélateur
des problèmes posés par la construction
européenne à plusieurs niveaux déjà au
niveau de la production
il faut savoir que
nous sommes comme un grand pays en
principe industriel un grand pays du
vaccin il ya vos confrères et
concurrents du monde ont fait il ya
quelques semaines un reportage très
intéressant faire un papier très
intéressant sur comment créer l'institut
crémieux avait un avis donc à une
entreprise française les vacciner tout
le brésil en urgence en 1975 et
maintenant on n'arrive plus à se
vacciner soi-même si vous voulez donc au
niveau de la production déjà qu'est ce
qui est de qu'est ce qu'est devenue la
production française notamment en
matière de santé pourquoi nous n'avons
pas notre propre vaccin
ça c'est un vrai problème donc qu'est
devenu notre industrie et notre notre
savoir scientifique ça peut être un
petit rapport avec l'europe
d'ailleurs si ça allait bien on nous
dirait que c'est grâce à l'europe ben là
c'est quand même par bruxelles las pour
le koki qui a empêché sanofi de trouver
un vaccin non on peut penser si vous
voulez que l'éclat des centrales il faut
que la construction européenne a
effectivement en ce domaine comme
d'autres plutôt nui à notre industrie
en tout cas c'est ce que disent les
chiffres que le contraire ensuite vous
avez un autre élément qui est lui plus
facile à prouver ou vous la corde c'est
que quand la crise il ya exactement un
an quand la crise a pris un tour
paroxystique et quand il ya eu le
confinement
chacun s'est retourné vers 2 comment
dirais-je de paul affectif sa famille
les vents se sont retrouvés et la nation
et ça a été le cas en france était le
cas partout ailleurs
les italiens ont réagi comme italiens
ont chanté vous rappelez sur les balcons
des airs patriotiques ont brandi des
drapeaux italiens les allemands ont
réagi comme des allemands les anglais
ont réagi comme daoud et enfin les
britanniques et vous avez à ce moment là
bien vu qu est-ce qui comptait et de
fait ce que nous décrit notre premier
ministre tout l'instant c'est bien une
forme de concurrence entre les nations
alors on peut trouver ça dommage en
exemple c'est dommage que les européens
à sopot européen nous on peut constater
plutôt que d'être normatif on peut
constater que jusqu'à présent les
britanniques restent des britanniques
les allemands des allemands les français
des français et que donc on réagit en
fonction de notre collectivité
d'appartenance notre comme il sait
affective et que de ce point de vue là
l'europe n'apparaît pas comme une
instance de protection quelconque cette
troisième point c'est qu'on a toujours
vendu l'europe comme une instance de
protection
c'est cela depuis au-moins 1992 et en
disant ça nous évite la guerre mais plus
en plus ça nous protège de manière
de toutes sortes de mots là visiblement
ce n'est pas le cas et puis d'aller là
dessus il ya un fait très cruel ça fait
des années qu'on décrit le break sites
comme une catastrophe incroyable comme
une forme de suicide collectif des
britanniques
on voit que visiblement en ce domaine
aussi le break site n'a pas apporté les
conséquences tragiques que l'on nous
annonçait ou en ce domaine
en tout cas parce que pour le reste on
économise ça a l'air de ne pas être
quand même complètement simple si on
reprend les éléments factuels mathieu
sous caire qui fait qu' on a décidé de
mutualiser avec l'europe en europe
plutôt nos achats de vaccins
le premier cas c'était le premier point
c'était pour les avoir moins cher mais
est ce que vous êtes d'accord ou est ce
que c'est un peu provocateur de dire que
avoir moins cher des vaccins qu'on n'a
pas ça n'apporte pas grand chose en
effet à ce stade encore une fois je note
que les officiels européens et même les
nôtres ne modifient pas leurs objectifs
de vaccination à l'été il ya des retards
qui sont aujourd'hui enregistrer qui
s'aggrave même mais encore une fois tout
le monde considère que d'ici la fin de
l'été qui encore une fois le terme qui
est fixé depuis le départ malgré tout on
aura fait le job était maintenant parce
que c'est important de vacciner le plus
vite possible mais je joue je crois que
c'est très important et je crois qu'en
fait tout le monde est d'accord avec cet
objectif je crois il les laboratoires
qui fabriquent eux-mêmes les vaccins et
tous les gouvernements qui sont par
ailleurs eux-mêmes soumis à une pression
très forte de la part de leur opinion
je suis néanmoins en désaccord avec à
peu près tout ce qu'a dit jérôme sur sur
l'europe et le raté de l'europe
première chose c'est anecdotique mais
néanmoins vous citer l'exemple de chaque
pays européen qui chaque soir à 20h
sortait sur son balcon pour pour chanter
avec le drapeau de son pays et c'est
effectivement on est pas tous sortis
avec le drapeau européen
on ne peut d'ailleurs pas tous sortis
avec des drapeaux femme je suis sorti
tous les soirs avec les enfants sur mon
balcon pour applaudir mais sans drapeau
en tout état de cause il se trouve que
nous avons tous en europe
adopté à peu près le même rituel je ne
crois pas qu aux états unis ou en asie
on est procédé de la même façon gibeau
malgré tout une forme de petits fonds
culturel commun nous avons tous
spontanément adopté le même rite à 20h
pour défendre nos services publics à la
française
mais d'une certaine façon nos services
publics à l'européenne je note deuxième
dimensions qu' il y a une forme de
communauté de valeurs qui fait que c'est
en europe que dès que le virus est
arrivé on a décrété que l'économie
devait être mise sous cloche que la vie
sociale devait être mise tout sur pause
car à ce moment là ce qui prévalait
avant toute autre considération
c'était la vie humaine là où à l'époque
le président trump a avec le la facétie
qu'on peut lui reconnaître 10 est
rigoureusement inverse où son compère
boyzone arrow disait aussi l' inverse
donc à l'époque c'est l'europe qui a dit
la vie passe avant l'économie
aujourd'hui évidemment on observe les
choses avec recul de façon un peu
différente mais à ce moment là quand
même
il y a eu 7 7 7 communauté de valeurs et
cette communauté l'action est encore une
fois dernière dimension vous parliez de
concurrence en fait entre états nations
il y a eu à la faveur de cette crise
pour la première fois ou en tout cas à
un niveau jusqu alors inconnu une
solidarité entre états européens à
travers deux choses la remise en cause
de ce qu'était le dogme budgétaires
jusqu'à présent et avec l'allemagne qui
a fait un énorme pas de côté en quittant
le camp des frigos pour rejoindre celui
des ddd solidaire et deuxième dimension
encore une fois on a mutualisé les
choses comme jamais on l'avait fait donc
il ya encore de la concurrence vous avez
raison il ya encore du nationalisme il
ya encore parfois comment un cadre
d'action qui reste nationale personne ne
le conteste mais il ya eu quand même
pour la première fois un bond en avant
dans la solidarité européenne
donc je suis pas je suis pas d'accord
avec la façon dont vous présentez les
choses nos internautes sentent
assez sévère et de considérer à 72%
ce n'est pas une c'est une majorité
absolue est large même si ça n'est pas
unanime que on peut attribuer à l'europe
l'échec de la campagne vaccinale même si
mathus ou café bien de le rappeler la
campagne n'est pas finie et que c'est à
la fin de la guerre qu'on sait qui a
gagné pour répondre à votre internaute
quand même à ce stade c'est néanmoins
l'europe qui a fait qui a passé les plus
importantes précommandes de vaccins qui
l'a fait volontairement en fait en
commandant des vaccins à aux différents
laboratoires pour diversifier ses
sources d'approvisionnement et les
sécurise et les sécuriser vous vous
m'accorderez effectivement enfin je vous
accorde plus exactement que à ce stade
ça n'est pas manifeste mais il y avait
une stratégie de sécurisation quand même
des approvisionnements et dernier
élément effectivement l'europe a voulu
peser collectivement 1 pour aider les
plus petits états a bien négocié et le
la stratégie de négociation de l'europe
a au moins pour ce qui est de la
négociation des prix comme le suggérait
tout à l'heure a été relativement
efficace puisque les vaccins ont été
acquis pour un prix inférieur de 30% à
celui qu'ont décaisser les états unis
voilà quand ils arriveront ce sera
encore mieux encore le chardon bleu il
faudrait d'urgence commandé des vaccins
sans passer par l'union européenne au
laboratoire pfizer et moderna c'est une
préconisation un syndicaliste c'est son
pseudonyme probablement sur lefigaro.fr
vous explique que l'union européenne a
fait le choix de la prudence et à deux
problèmes la lourdeur bureaucratique et
fait qu'il n'y ait aucun vaccin européen
ou presque
oui même si si ils sont largement
reproduits sur le sol européen
théo nous rappelle comme vous le faisiez
mathieu soupière sur twitter que la
santé ne fait pas partie de la
compétence de l'europe tort
il faut arrêter de trouver des
responsables l'ancien gouvernement
l'europe
ils ne sont pas responsables des
politiques intérieures actuelle et puis
babineau qui trouve choquant l'opacité
totale sur les contrats entre l'union
européenne et les laboratoires
nicole 06 qui nous rappelle sur le
figaro.fr que les français qui ont
travaillé sur les vaccins avec un
certain succès sont tous ailleurs qu'en
france vous faites probablement allusion
à modern ac est une entreprise
américaine mais fondée pas fondées
d'ailleurs mais en tout cas dirigée par
un français
et puis encore un commentaire de
babineau la gestion de la crise du
coronavirus de boris johnson n'a pas été
brillante mais sa stratégie vaccinale
est irréprochable
un dernier point jérôme sainte-marie
vous êtes d'accord que l'europe en tout
cas ça a servi à quelque chose c'est
vrai que c'était pas pour la vaccination
mais c'était le vdd des centaines de
milliards d'euros qui vont nous
permettre de repartir ça c'est bien
d'avoir mutualisé ça j'allais venir
effectivement parce que si je me place
du point de vue de l'opinion est en
sondeurs que pensent les français de
tout cela alors je paye tous d'accord
mais ça c'est une perception sur le fait
que l'on fait un procès systématique à
l'europe c'est exactement le contraire
que ce soit à l'école à la télévision
publique
ou bien on a entendu notre présent de la
république à l'instant au contraire
c'est sans cesse sans cesse un discours
je ne peux pas parler de propagande mais
un discours disant très laudatif très
optimiste sur l'europe on a entendu un
instant emmanuel macron les français par
rapport à cela
il juge l'arbre à ses fruits donc en
matière sanitaire sur les conditions de
lutte contre la pandémie
ils vont le fait d'invoquer en
permanence l'europe ne rend pas un grand
service à l'europe parce qu'on voit bien
que ça se passe mal on perd du temps au
minimum qu'il ya une confusion extrême
on à culpabiliser les français et pas
longtemps sur le fait que partent ils ne
voulaient pas de vacciner puis
maintenant on retire les vaccins enfin
c'est un véritablement désastreux il ya
un point sur lequel effectivement les
français je pense vont beaucoup comment
dirais-je importants et ils vont croire
je pense qu'ils vont croire
qu'effectivement l'europe a permis via
notamment l'euro justement que verrait
finalement on traverse depuis un an
cette crise économique aussi à 100 que
et les pensions les fonctionnaires n'ont
pas perdu un euro afin de recouper à
autant de salaires les retraités sur
leurs pensions sont toujours payés etc
et on a beau avoir un à un comment
dirais-je à une balance commerciale
désastreuse une des problèmes une
désindustrialisation massive et bien
malgré tout ça continue à l'argent
continuent à arriver
on n'a même plus le gouvernement a pu
aussi déployé des aides très important
pour les entreprises pour les salariés
etc et on se dit mais tout cela c'est
parce que on est couvert par l'euro et
qu'enfin on a pu emprunter
sauf que quand on regarde les conditions
de l'emprunt
ce ne sont pas forcément des conditions
très avantageuses ce serait une autre
émission si vous voulez mais là
effectivement il ya eu le parapluie de
l'euro mais le cou à la sortie à mon
avis va être extraordinairement grave
nature rebondir sur ce point très
rapidement puisque j'ai le sentiment que
jérôme se contredit un peu tout à leur
disait on attend de l'europe qu'elle
nous protège
en été on observe qu'elle nous protège
pas en vous venez précisément d'égrainer
des chiffres qui démontrent qu'on
comment l'europe a souhaité nous
protéger dès le départ est juste un seul
exemple le chômage parce qu'on appelle
le chômage partiel
c'est le choix que la france a fait en
premier mais c'est le choix que
l'ensemble des pays européens mais en
fait nous est axée sur terre nous sommes
à tra sa coute trés jeu sommes encore un
très grand pays c'est pas l'europe qui
fait que c'est possible je sue les pays
européens ont choisi pour des raisons
sociales de privilégier l'option du
chômage partiel sur le m messieurs c'est
promis on en reparlera puisque ça vous
passionne et à juste titre la gestion
économique par l'europe de cette crise
parlons d'anne hidalgo s'il voulait bien
lé maire de paris mais c'est pourtant à
douelle qu'elle a choisi aujourd'hui de
lancer officiellement sa plate forme
d'idées en commun l'objectif est de
fédérer les énergies dans une
perspective d'une candidature à la
présidence de la république en 2022 elle
annonce déjà le soutien de mer bien
connus comme françois rebsamen maire de
dijon martine aubry maire de lille ou
johanna rolland maire de nantes et dans
une interview ce matin à la voix du nord
elle explique un peu son son son
positionnement son projet c'est
construire une alternative basée sur une
conjugaison de l'écologie et du social
ça ressemble à quelque chose d'assez
prometteur d'ailleurs ces deux là dessus
qu'elle a été élue est très bien réélu à
paris et pourtant pour l'instant dans
les sondages ça décolle pas trop alors
c'est vrai que dans les sondages
commencent à être un peu anciens
maintenant puisque de fin janvier
mais peut-être qu'un à d'autres depuis
vous allez nous le dira jérôme
sainte-marie harris interactive
elle était à 6% c'est à dire derrière
nicolas dupont aignan ce que pas
forcément un score mirifique est-ce que
ça va mieux depuis ça est ce que ça
prend la candidature hidalgo jérôme
qu'est ce qu'on dit dans vos dans vos
sandales ans il ya un sondage qui est
juste de sortir cet après midi donc
aujourd'hui mercredi
réalisé par l'ifop et publié par
marianne qui donne des ailes go à 8%
alors là dessus lui pour s'en servir
pour us 2 points en un mois et demi
c'est des intentions de vote et des
préférences de vote sur une offre
électorale que les interviewés découvre
parce qu'en réalité beaucoup énormément
de gens ne savent pas du tout n'envisage
pas du tout la campagne d'anne hidalgo
les d'une part on vient de parler du coc
ville les gens ont autre chose à penser
et puis par ailleurs vous avez on sait
personne ne sait réellement enfin enfin
la plupart ces campagnes non plus une
personnalité totalement enfin écrasante
médiatiquement pour l'instant et c'est
difficile pour les gens de d'exprimer
une intention de vote pour quelqu'un
dont ils sont même pas sûr qu'elle soit
candidate
donc seules 8% est un chiffre qui n'est
pas négligeable par rapport au précédent
c'est plutôt en train de monter et on
peut penser qu'elle a encore un achat
important potentiel
je ne suis même pas sûr sa notoriété
soit immense anne hidalgo auprès de la
france et vous savez c'est les parisiens
la connaissent bien les franciliens
aussi
beaucoup de gens à mon avis
l'identifient assez peu donc c'est 8%
soit un résultat qui est un rite un
chiffre de départ on s'est pas encore
prier pour elle
moi je pense que c'est complètement plié
mais pour d'autres raisons et si vous
voulez d'un point de vue grc lui pour
cent vous me dites est ce que ça peut
monter wyss a déjà monté ça montera
encore probablement après il me semble
qu'un suspense est insupportable dit
nous on ignore pourquoi ces pluies
raviver nocives ou le sait déjà c'est
une candidate de gauche donc tous ceux
qui ne seront pas à gauche a fait du
monde dans le pays actuellement ne
voterai pas pour elle en plus elle
incarne elle est parfois caricaturé
comme la candidate des bobos et cetera
parisien donc ça peut pas la rendre très
populaire par ailleurs elle est
confrontée à une situation dans la
gauche alliée profondes divisions
notamment si anne hidalgo se présente je
crois que jean luc mélenchon est encore
plus de se sentir et encore plus
justifié de le faire elle incarne bien
la tradition socialiste la tradition
solférinien m comme il disait aligne
certaine époque elle incarne la gauche
font le pont avec l'europe
elle incarne parfaitement la gauche qui
a voté oui en 2005
mais jean-luc mélenchon et ont plutôt la
gauche qui a voté non c'est pas les
mamies de logis c'est pas le même milieu
social non plus c'est pas la même
clientèle électorale et c'est pour ça
que je pense que elle peut faire un bon
score au sein de la gauche ce qu'il a ce
qui est très très loin de la qualifier
pour le second tour de la présidentielle
est-ce que mathieu ce qui avoue partager
ce scepticisme sainte-marien jeu comme
on dit qui est celui de jérôme sainte
marie
alors je je n'avais pas en tête le
sondage de cet après midi qu'il a donnée
à 8%
le plus récent que moi j'avais en tête
était aussi un sondage de l'ifop pour le
jdd qui début du mois de février il me
semble qu'il a donné à 13 % ce qui était
un peu mieux que 6 un peu moqueuse pour
13% en candidat unique de la gauche
oui voilà c'est pour ça qu'en la
personne a pris celui là même prix on
avait pris un plus ouvert absolument la
concurrence c'est ça alors ce qui est
sûr c'est que le jeu ne sais pas dans
quelle mesure le contexte lui est
favorable
on a globalement une société française
qui a continué de se droitiser en fait
pendant tout le mandat de d'emmanuel
macron on a encore une fois on
déjà dit une gauche politique qui a fini
le précédent quinquennat totalement
exsangues et qui a eu beaucoup de mal à
ceux à se reconstruire alors il ya une
dynamique du côté des écologistes en
tout cas on a pu l'observer et aux
européennes et aux municipales mais on
voit bien que la gauche a du mal à se
refaire la cerise
alors 6 8 ou 13 pour cent c'est un socle
non négligeable c'est pas un socle
considérable mais c'est un saut que non
négligeable et là je rejoins je rejoins
jérôme c'est un socle sur lequel elle
peut capitaliser pour augmenter l aele a
tout de même des qualités
anne hidalgo ou quoi qu'on pense de son
action à paris elle a démontré qu'elle
était une candidate relativement
redoutable en tout cas aux municipales
elle a mené deux campagnes qui lui ont
permis de croquer nkm dans un premier
temps et ensuite rachida basile rachida
dati pardon et agnès buzyn et donc elle
a fait deux campagnes relativement
remarquable elle a une capacité de
résilience et de rebond qui vaut celle
d' emmanuel macron c'est à dire que elle
a connu les affres si ce n'est de
l'impopularité en tout cas de critiques
très sévères quant à sa gestion
municipale à paris autour de vélib
autolib et c'est plein de choses et puis
elle est remonté petit à petit elle est
remonté on l'a même doté d'une capacité
de résistance et d'une combativité
relativement rare et ça c'est
incontestable et ça peut lui donner lui
donner quand même une force tout à fait
considérable
on vous sent assez séduit non alors je
dis pas ça j'essaye de faire une énorme
jeu en l'occurrence jeu c'est de faire
une analyse assez assez froides de la
situation
la question aussi est celle des
concurrents à gauche françois hollande
ségolène royal arnaud montebourg
ce qui pour l'instant sont sortis du
bois je ne sais pas dans quelle mesure
ils disposent en a été d'un ressort d'un
potentiel électoral plus élevé il ya
quand même leur ligne de l'ifop pour
paris match
kiki place hidalgo plutôt pas mal autour
de 40% alors c'est loin des 65 ou 70% de
nicolas hulot ça se sont mis à niveau de
popularité les niveaux absolument on est
au niveau de popularité mais elle est à
40% alors j'étais surpris de voir qu
elle l est est la troisième personnalité
à gauche et qu'elle était derrière
martine aubry et même derrière françois
hollande mais il n'empêche qu'elle est
dans le disons dans le quarté de ceux
qui peuvent incarner la gauche demain
ensuite je rejoins ce que dit ce que
jérôme sur l'électorat qui pourrait la
faire rennes après l'avoir fait mr je ne
suis pas sûr qu'elle incarne la gauche
solférinien parce qu'elle n'a jamais été
prise en fait dans tous les jeux
d'appareil ne s'est jamais montrée au
sein du ps au bureau national ou
ailleurs on jettera un spécialiste la
gauche algérienne c'est à les gens à la
rue de solférino siège du parti
socialiste en gros c'est la gauche de
gouvernement ou la gauche le parti
socialiste comme système est précisément
elle n'a jamais baigné là dedans et à la
fonder en réalité sa légitimité sur sa
seule action municipale dès le terrain
et dans l'interview qu'elle donne ce
matin à la voix du nord justement elle
donne bien à voir qu'elle est entourée
de cette jeune génération d'élus locaux
de gens près jules proche du terrain de
de toute cette intelligence en fait du
terrain qu'incarne la société civile
elle cite également quelques
intellectuels et cédera donc au
contraire elle montre bien qu'elle est
très éloignée de la logique des partis
des organisations et que sa force à elle
c'est celle qu'elle tient du terrain et
de l'ag et de la légitimité de son
action et de son action locale
en revanche un sujet quand même sur
l'électorat qui est le sien je ne sais
pas si c'est la candidate des bobos
parisiens
en tout état de cause on voit bien
quelle pourrait être une candidate
légitime pour la population des grandes
métropoles qui est précisément celle qui
à ce stade est également séduite par
emmanuelle marty c'est un peu la vie de
nos internautes au fait que qu'anne
hidalgo soit un petit peu marqué bennett
sur youtube de 10 elle convient très
bien certainement à l'employé de bobos
qui votent pour la liste socialiste à
paris mais elle n'a pas l'envergure ni
l'image dit le contact pour la france
entière envahie on va y revenir
orphée à sur youtube trouve qu'il
faudrait du sang neuf dans la politique
et que on en a assez de cette caste qui
n'existe que pour elle est d'ailleurs
sur twitter quand on vous pose la
question croyez vous à la candidature
d'ali d'algos
vous répondez non à 81 2% évidence pas
un sondage 1 c'est l'avis de des
internautes qui sont en train de nous
suivre en direct sur lefigaro.fr ou sur
youtube
maxime nous dit oui elle peut se
présenter mais sous quelle étiquette at
elle vraiment une chance de gagner en
étant socialiste quant à drac ofid sur
youtube il pense où elles pensent que l
hidalgo préféra rester maire de paris
c'est un post sur alors que la
présidentielle risquent davantage de
l'éprouver qu'autre chose surtout au vu
de la popularité de la gauche en ce
moment et élan sur lefigaro.fr nous dit
toute la france à 30 km heure parce que
vous savez que c'est le dernier projet
de la mairie de paris c'est de
généraliser la limitation de vitesse à
30 km heure dans les rues de la capitale
ça c'est un point
jérôme sainte-marie est ce qu'on peut
être élu président la république en
étant maire de paris et la réponse est
oui parce qu'il ya eu jacques chirac est
ce que la comparaison est valable oui
nous avons eu 22 vous répondre je
concède effectivement à thiès où pierre
que la dimension solférino yens que
j'évoquais peuvent tirer pour être un
argument utilisé par ses concurrents
notamment du côté de la france un
sioniste mais de fait ce ne serait pas
un argument très pertinent puisque et de
fait elle est pas si je vais si j'ose
dire compromise avec les vicissitudes de
la vie interne du parti socialiste en
tout cas pas aux yeux de l'opinion
publique
elle a construit son image effectivement
sur une dimension très personnelle et
très paris très très local on va dire
sur comme pour répondre véritablement je
ne crois pas que ça qu'elles puissent
accéder au second tour et je pense en
plus qu'elle pour a d'autres moi que
dans le sondage qui vient d'être publiée
il ya une question ce qui est très
bizarre d'ailleurs de second tour qui a
été posée avec marine le pen contre anne
hidalgo c'est curieux parce qu' elle
n'est pas donnée qualifiée pour le
second tour alors apparemment je vais
pas commencer
quelle est la jurisprudence voilà bon là
dessus maintenant mais en tout cas bon
ça a été testée cet intéressant comme
toute chose qui est et qui sont testés
et là elle serait battu par marine le
pen donc qu'à 51 49
ces chiffres on est tous d'accord ne
veulent rien dire mais en tout cas ça
projette une image qui est pas c'est pas
vraiment un recours alors à quoi c'est
pourquoi l'accord la candidature d'un
cargo serait utile elle serait utile
d'agen a pas mal d'élus socialistes
notamment dans les grandes villes élus
de gauche qui disent tiens on a un
candidat ou une candidate qui est assez
prévisible
qui donc on apprend qui nous inquiète
pas trop et qui pourrait faire un bon
score
or c'est quand même pas mal ils n'ont
pas envie ces élus de la gauche modérée
de la gauche européenne d'être obligé de
se mettre forcément derrière un
écologiste et encore moins derrière
jean-luc mélenchon donc déjà ça peut
être un débouché électoral
une élève comme ça et fera son score ça
sera pas déshonorant et dans les
métropoles devraient faire un score non
négligeable pourquoi pas c'est déjà ces
pratiques
et puis surtout ça notre intérêt c'est
que j'ai lu m'a l'air l'interview dans
la voix du nord la de ceux d'aujourd'hui
bon a dit pas grand chose
qu'est ce qu'ils reprochent un maquereau
alors j'ai regardé ça ben il et il n'a
pas fait assez sur la question sociale
il n'a pas fait assez dans le dialogue
avec la société bon ben ça ce serait
outré facilement vous annoncez emmanuel
macron pourra toujours
second tour annoncé qu'il déclenche une
énième allocations que l'égalité va
s'accroître l'égalité de genre et c'est
tout ça ne mange pas de pain est par
ailleurs le dialogue avec la société ben
l'annoncera tel ou tel dispositif
citoyens consultatif et tout le monde
sera content et elle du coup devient
très utile anne hidalgo
parce qu'à ce moment là contrairement à
jean luc mélenchon qui a annoncé qu'il
appellerait pas à voter au second tour
pour les deux candidats qui sont
actuellement les plus probables
et bien l on est assuré qu'elle
appellera à voter pour emmanuel macron
contre marine le pen est donc vous voyez
qu'elle a une utilité sociale et
politique tournée jobs les bains écoutez
vous voyez loin c'est pour ça qu'on est
toujours heureux de vous accueillir
daniel sur twitter nous dit qu'elle
n'est déjà pas capable de s'occuper de
paris alors la france 3 petits points
lourd de sous-entendus et puis marc
antoine berry sur youtube
je pense que sa candidature enlèverait
des points à maquereau et serait ainsi
une bonne nouvelle pour marine le pen
alors au premier tour peut-être mais au
second tour pas forcément cher marc
antoine en tout cas telle est l'analyse
de jérôme sainte-marie merci beaucoup à
tous les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci à vous de nous avoir
suivi on rend l'antenne parce qu'on est
un petit peu en retard et à demain pour
de nouvelles aventures
[Musique]